crab feast you know it's all about this
is the crappy I'm yelling [ __ ] that you
wait out a half me cuz you could trust
that every to Z you already know ryan
paint with socks off you go above-ground
pool goes better than most jane austen
self-diagnose go download this week last
week and we never get from so crappy
[Music]
all
want to grab beat ya'll know Susie I'll
the crabbies righthand God there were
parts in there where I couldn't even
hear my own question I could just feel
yours so good to touch your picture Lord
you get a little fresh hello you know
little sec so good to be here with you
sickle-cell feast nation always glad to
be here with you much love to all of you
the only thing I really promoting I'm
just doing shows i usually tweet or
instagram and always at the rabbit hole
on wednesday nights and my vinyl release
of my album is available i have it on
all my social media i love it if you
went and purchased it it's only 15 bucks
over at a special thing com that's where
it's available i have the link on my
website again it's I'm really proud of
it it's red you know we get the final
grade that is a great pretty cool and
it's just a really cool to have my own
album especially since we have the
record player at home and and it gets
read excited when he hears me on it so
again that's just at my website Jay
Larson calm be calm all my social media
Jay Larson comedy I love you guys glad
to be with here every week and sickle
cells are so glad to be with you buddy
how are you I'm glad to be with you and
glad many different body had to be with
here too man yeah you forgot all social
media Ryan Sickler calm definitely go by
Jay Larson's album that's what I'm going
to promote also thank you for having me
on the rabbit hole it's such a fun show
such a great show guys got a great vibe
in that room is building it is really
fun and I'm going to give a little love
out to the crap shoot comedy festival
may 18th to the 20th men in Las Vegas
check that out it's got Dave Attell be
there i'm pretty sure Bert Kreischer
will be there it's going to be a good
time come on out to that if you're in
Vegas crab feast calm where you can get
your merch and you can do all your
amazon shopping Thank You pleasing your
amazon shopping premium apps and make
sure you follow the crab feast on
facebook and twitter i did want to say
one more thing i just told this guy
tried you bet you if you were focused on
you focused me but march forth so i'll
be doing a benefit for the Sklar
brothers they're hosting and putting it
on Nick soon bill burr
alice wetterlund it's a stack lineup
tickets are available i posted on my
social media but that's a great show in
town for a good cause as well i'll tell
you you know you can get tickets that
way through us but if you want to get
tickets to an event or walk along like
what if you want to get tickets to an
event it's usually kind of confusing you
want to go to a concert or a sports
sporting event looking online you never
know where you're going to get the best
deal seatgeek has stepped up they do it
a little different they've come along
and create an amazing app and website
that makes it easier easier than ever
for fans to buy and sell tickets
seatgeek is always the first place I go
and most recently I bought tickets to
the Celtics to come into town so I went
to see geek I'm gonna go see capitals
king and I'm also going to see Clippers
Wiz you're gonna go see the capital play
the wings Kings Kings gotcha anyway I'm
going march six I'm stoked about it see
geek dialed at all in all through c2
equals my point exactly i got the C key
cap go on there it's pretty easy C keek
does all the price comparison for you by
searching multiple ticket sites and
ensuring that you get the best possible
deal seatgeek does all the work and you
save all the time and money all of our
listeners here's the best deal we're
offering $20 rebate off your first
seatgeek purchase boom get to get you
twenty dollar rebate download the seat
geek app go to the Settings tab and
click add a promo code enter promo code
crap CR a B and C geek will send you
twenty dollars after you've made your
first ticket purchase download the seat
geek app and enter promo code crab CRA
be today we also have another great
sponsor called skillshare it's a brand
new sponsor and we're so stoked that
mirror baby uh well I guy got Skillshare
is a membership that that offers a bunch
of different classes it's so easy to use
you sign up and like let's say you want
to fine tune a specific skill or find a
way to do your job more efficiently
maybe you've always thought of signing
up for that photography class or I know
for me editing I've always wanted to do
getting better but you never get around
to it you know maybe your professional
looking for a leg up at work or just
someone who loves learning new things
they have classes for everything
everything you want to brush up on
Photoshop boom it's their photography
it's taught by industry leaders and
expert practitioners in their field
membership includes access to over
14,000 classes and their classes for
everyone freelancers to corporate
entrepreneurs to help you further your
career if you want some just for fun
classes like watercolor crafts or
calligraphy whatever you want I'll your
calligraphy my calligraphy actually
could use some help that's why I signed
us up for one of those it's for both of
us actually and some of a really cool
where they'll give you a class project
actual homework and then you submit it
and you'll get feedback on and
everything as a class project in every
class so are you ready to accelerate
your skill development then go to ww
skillshare calm / crab feast to get your
first month free get access to any class
on any skill you want to learn or want
to fine tune skillshare is giving our
listeners a free month of access I'm
telling you it's worth it go sign up
check it out go to ww Skillshare calm /
crab feast well the only place you need
to go for this week's episode is right
here you're there guys you are there
you're here y'all and I'll tell you
right now we're excited it's uh always
always a pleasure when we have this guy
on and excited to have him back please
welcome back to the craft fees Gary
Reynolds everybody grab a couple things
right off the taco Karis okay be super
clear scarce and second of all sounded
like you stumbled over the excitement a
little like you sort of like I know Ely
you sure I mean namal you are fired up
that I'm here what is it completely yeah
okay completely and totally fired up
here well how many times you've been on
though this is my well this is my second
that will be released for a part of a
lost episode yeah sort of a lost live oh
yeah yeah yeah but you guys I guess
interesting have some beef with me about
not gonna lie I'm glad we start
recording I thought I was gonna get my
ass kicked before we started this is
best thing about Gareth room you can
just start [ __ ] around the second you
see him he's going to roll at all online
yes Anderson baby ah so why don't you
all look a lot you please social media
your podcasts all I fine now you can
find me at Reynolds Gareth on social
media on instagram and twitter my
podcast I have to podcast one's called
the dollop which is an American history
podcast with Dave Anthony and then I do
another one called point versus point
with Evan man which is a weekly debate
show turn events debate you yeah mm-hmm
that's great you guys some shorts are
you just doing the podcast now I know I
mean we you know we're like writing
partner so I work with him a lot but no
we don't do show got any more will do
stuff ever known them yeah I mean that's
how I that's how I became aware of you
yeah I mean yeah that's what look the
industry took notice as you can tell I
mean got into hargett you book oh yeah
no it wasn't how many times you get the
tech I won't yeah yeah and I called back
and he didn't answer and I text if I did
that awkward thing and I just texted
back I'm like I'm for sure I but I yeah
but doubt i'll bring food anything you
guys want me to call me back i wanna
took your car ah and 54 @ prior prior to
the country um so I hit you up and I
said you know what you're always a great
time you got to come back on you said
I've got one for you yeah I want to hear
like let's well and then he told a
little bit before me Oh didn't sound
right yeah yeah heard her shout out
first yeah oh yeah well there's a guy
I've never met this guy but he's a guy
who's for whatever reason has just been
like a guy who whenever you know
whenever there's anything on Twitter he
listens to everything he's very
supportive I known through the naughty
show but his name is Glen Carlin he's
this Irish dude I'm a he probably
deserves a blow-up just gon Carlin yeah
glencar one in one that doesn't get
funky with it double check see I'm what
will give you the wrong car ever do to
get my email did your pretty to get my
email yeah did you produce you get my
email cuz i emailed about this when you
guys tell me about them yeah turn the
mic on a guy goes hollywood guys 2 n's
glencar la isla a little both up god
damn it the water and
Island bugging the one in college like
who the [ __ ] well because I get wreath
around that's actually Gareth again I
think we you know it and we that it's
the right time everywhere real know how
did it become Gary know the date baby he
started calling you Gary or hey man
[ __ ] it up and no ran well no Dave
started calling me Gary Dave Jackson
around no it wasn't one day like on one
day hello you got that one right huh one
day we were just doing the podcast early
and he was just like yeah just call me
Gary I was like what no its Gareth and
then weeks rolled into months rolled
into Tanner poster oh yeah so I'm you're
the Guardian The Guardian which my
family take my family lives in England
and the Guardian did this thing of like
whenever we're on this list of the
Guardian there's little write-up in the
dude call me Gary the whole time he was
like doing a bit not like this some kind
of a bit like you're in the winner's
circle but by the wrong maybe like thank
you but also graphically your mobile
kitchen I thought Gareth was going to be
in the face Britney customers always
guarantee you Karen no they're not and
also we're I I don't know I don't know
who that will Melman what did your mom
sound like does she have it is like that
oh yeah sick real sick sick British
accent yeah she like American accent if
you look south let me know yeah not my
mother talks like this she was it like a
timer and get her on you guys all right
sorry see I'm already trying to already
try to beef up as up with this is sweet
right yeah sweeps week reading the
sweeps and they're uh you know Matthew
Perry what do you guys want to do is
everyone hey Mary the list goes on and
on name them out of those two name
either one I can get them so we may have
thought about this before but I just
forget your parents your family from
England first came here had you guys
then went back or so my parents my my
parents are immigrants they moved from
England to it's a tough time along with
river but yeah came from Spain yeah oh
yeah
a mammogram different culture England I
pan yeah so they they moved to Wisconsin
eventually had me my brother was already
English and they made a really weird
trance / from england to milwaukee
wisconsin yeah and my mother thought she
was like moving to Beverly Hills because
that's really like in England like
they're like what's it like in Beverly
Hills you're like I live in Wisconsin
they're like what's my videos I know you
like it what's it like and so that my
mother moved to Wisconsin it was like a
negative 70-degree windshield was like
where the bright lights of Hollywood you
know it's just it's just like throwing
logs in the fire what made them just
drop a pin on milwaukee yeah why dad got
a job offer so they started in columbus
and then everything is a brag with him
shut up note i mean my dad was water I
got my dad was work first of all yeah
yes and then they got divorced in just
terrific fashion and that mean things
were good everything was fine there was
they had you know basically for my
mother a deal breaker was when my dad
was you know seeing someone else and she
was like you know oh my gosh you know I
want ya very particular like that' she
was like I you know I'm not a song yeah
so she goes you know that says to me
maybe you're not into this and you know
then that woman got pregnant anyway
really yeah yeah 35 bar any of those
how's my happy there your steps no you
have yeah right there yeah yeah they're
great yeah but airbrush there are no
they're Wisconsin kids oh you got ya so
he's got an American well he's got one
British kid yeah one roll me whatever
you call me or my brother have an accent
not really no he used to it turns up
when you like talked to English people
you go there yeah it really does it's
like right away the second i get them
like oh my neck is wicked suleiman you
know when i come back here if you like
what's going go get cigarettes in a jean
jacket the following yeah where's the
bus man [ __ ] this yeah [ __ ] the Queen
mon and I was a kid I had I don't even
know how my parents let me wear but i
bought i love that def leppard that the
UK
I pretty amazed that you're talking
about a bike asli sir Evers wanted like
to leave I mean I wore sleep I wore a
long sleeve t under but it was a
sleeveless dick it was a sleeveless
British flag like I'm like oh yeah he's
gonna cover get answers your smokes or
do you come one of the Swedes over to
the drummer my god those are you sponge
if you tow it up and sew it up sure you
give millions even on the show haha I've
got one great story oh man you won't
believe this one are you not gonna bleep
I was no problem for the biggest band in
the world I let you yeah then he lost it
right yeah on the milling and then they
were like oh [ __ ] mammals good knowing
you and he was like I think I could
still play and they were like well you
know you're missing an arm which is kind
of a it's kind of a kill shot for a
drummer yeah and then he like showed him
a room of pedals and they were like oh
check this out I found out I be was good
what do you think [ __ ] I don't think
there's any way I was looking at a
friend my way I would bring up with you
things I'm not talking about he said he
sounds like a one-armed drummer and I
just started laughing cuz it does it's
just done your buddy today because he
just sounds like a one on drum early how
do you can't help it oh god she's just
come on I mean he's running uphill with
Sandra every time he drunk I think of
wormholes everything so I got the legs
that are just math but you save money on
drumsticks is there listen right I say
we keep them let someone tell us all
about sleeveless yes look at this hey
Marty yeah my god you said good set yeah
um so the number one of the baby so it's
just um you do awesome by the way you're
all of them europe or the way you turn
this around that is awesome so right
yeah i'll tell you that comeback kid hey
soft yarn over there doesn't that foot
pedal sounds just like an arm yo get
there safe ilu arm those right that
would be hilarious if the pedals wells
are it's just got one battle with an arm
like wrong this air
could you imagine though it ox4 at any
point if anyone's bitching about like
lodging of a long bus rides but that hey
man listen I've been playing what I want
on it is ami with the equipment man Oh
open is equipment just scraping his drum
kit I can get a roadie then we can't
afford another rowdy man what can you
[ __ ] can I take the tiniest speaker
I'll come on man be a team player oh all
right so your parents get divorced so I
parents get divorced dad has another
family did he get married yes no the the
escalation of what my debt it was almost
like my dad if you know I had just like
replaced everything so immediately so I
was like very quickly you know yeah he
had like a new family and I was like oh
cool um but I didn't want to talk to him
either because I was really pissed off
so then you know and you didn't wanna
move to lump back to England well she
didn't move to England until I'd left
later dad went back also no he lives in
wisconsin oh he did stay there so you
live with your mom I lived in my mom
yeah yeah doesn't know about their high
school yeah that's gotta be [ __ ]
weird that's fine man good age no it was
real weird yeah good you're gonna be
like I got one day I still people look
at me like I'm a drummer with one arm no
I was like yeah cuz I would like where I
went to school it was like a smaller
school and they were like like everybody
knew what was going on so it was just
sort of like you know like just felt
real weird you know was anyone giving
you [ __ ] about it uh not really [ __ ] but
I mean like ever like everybody I knew
had it seemed like they were from
perfect families yeah that my family was
like you know not I went to like a nicer
school boy family was like rap or wait
well yeah crash when we were transom oh
my god yeah not which family was better
on which is the Florida blue tonight
family family units the original family
was better than nine minus inversion
although the new version turned out was
better than the old family to a point
longer although in the end there was
another divorce so your dad divorced
that trick too yeah I been married
getting married Wow was it really oh
yeah yeah how are we ready on second
timer how was she when when
you got together with her she was dude
she was like 24 and he was like 45
what's up man yeah and you and like and
I'm here feels member here we must come
on come on hug your mother's a year
older though my brother was older so it
was like yeah she was like you know then
she was like a Wisconsin like bleach
blonde like permed hair like you know my
farm girl oh yeah yeah so she was sex
but divorce now now divorced now get
worse so you are close with your dear
brothers and sisters what do you have
over there hi have a brother an issue
from my mother in my fire and then I
have the three other brothers and sister
yeah who had a better family better
family who i love and who are great but
how many brothers and sisters on that
side three well brother to sister oh
it's real like yeah hold on first keep
askin i'll keep three of it three
minutes how many brothers sisters rate
LED ones are brother great ran an edge
to the question i think i think we're
pretty clear i think we're gonna move on
I think we're gonna move I don't know
how many more [ __ ] time line 1083
hahaha paid by the three going on would
you get too long fingers from your dad
or your mom look at me but how long the
fingers an idea like how he hands could
have been a quarterback man look at this
huh place worth growing up no I did
theater how are you reportage early man
I was like in one of you knew that you
were gonna be yeah that was I mean
definite something when you're older
yeah carpentry uh no I I was definitely
like yeah I gravitated towards that
right away like I honestly honestly
remember being seven years old being in
a play of Goldilocks and the three bears
and just being one of the Bears and like
getting a laugh and being like that'll
do yeah you know now I don't get this
anymore foot back then man they were
sweet meant a lot more your mom's alas
nine months to the best like the players
wives or my mother I got a lock I love
it yeah so you know my life's fine it's
fine it seems fine yeah so you were
telling us all
Mike you're going to a wedding in Mexico
was this wedding happen to be a family
member this was this is why my dad is
now taken five why well then listen you
two I on it hahaha so did say it from a
little under two years that you take
them on oh god amazing book stuff I was
yeah would it be married again by the
way yeah look a third now he has a
[ __ ] are yet I don't know but you bow
ties it you go to his wedding and
they're just like bridegroom or wife
there's three sections yes I go my buddy
is getting married in Mexico and I had
been working weekends on the show like
writing weekends and this was the last
weekend of it and the wedding was
saturday so my plan was I was like I'll
take a train to San Diego then I'll take
an uber to the border literally walk
across the border stay for the wedding
saturday guess he you wanna know is in a
Rosarita okay and so I'm like so
basically my plan is that saturday after
the wedding around like 4am I'll get up
I'll go to the train and I'll go back
and I'll work the sunday so I'm just
going to miss the Saturday because I'm
writing on the show on the weekends
right yeah so so go there friday night
falling all that [ __ ] as I give a speech
that was supposed to be a toast I've
misunderstood do it says exactly I was
like Sam give me the light this is just
a speech and they were like I saw him a
little thick it said toast but I was
like oh [ __ ] oh how far in before but I
was like I'm giving the speech you know
sigh so I you know gave like a condensed
version of the speech that was supposed
to be a toast how long did you work on
the speech you know let me not long a
train ride down is yeah yeah so about a
lot to me you know the whole experience
is very valuable no and so so at you
know as the day is going on like people
are like your there's no way you're
going to take a train back for you're
not going to get up at 4am and like
figure this out you know and I've had a
couple drinks so I'm like okay [ __ ] so I
decide I'm going to email my boss and I
email him I'm like hey I don't know what
I actually get back he's like dude
honestly if you just want to stay in
Mexico
you know I don't give a [ __ ] kill ya go
you know have fun and I was like okay so
i took that i was like i said i don't
even think i reflect it into like four
days later you know because i was so
locked in i was so happy so then said
we're partying then we get to the
wedding and the table that i'm at we
started calling table dose because it
was so clear that it was like the
degenerate I mean it was just so clearly
the degenerate table table2 yeah or the
people most no no it's Trump's America
you want we're trying to eliminate doses
aware that people understand so we're
like near the exits and and justifiably
so because you know everyone up to say
well yeah and then and they were
shitfaced everybody at our table showing
up or should face just like the second
after that the second the reception
started just the amount of shots and I
was like God dinner hasn't like this is
not this is not shaping up good so one
of the guys can't even make it through
to dinner so he leaves what do you mean
like can't make it he's so [ __ ] up
that he has to go to bed at like 630 Oh
astuces so and this is like a fairly
religious like half of the family is
fairly religious so then two guys at the
table one of the guys who's just
shit-canned gets up and either like
anyone want to give a speech and he's
like I'll give a speech she's like do I
he's like ID hosted yes yes if he's like
he keeps telling me like but you know
after my toe speech he's like yeah I
give good speeches I give great and
awesome whatever you know it is i have
great speeches so he give this speech of
this wedding that is so incoherent and
long and makes no sense and by the end
sits down and ones like doesn't know
what to do and he looks at me as like
told you since seen it back and is like
I don't know what's going on I don't
know what I'm talking about so then the
groom's like anyone else want to give a
speech to this dude at my table to his
drugs like I will and the guys like no
no more speeches from that today I'm
whole and then this guy gives a weird
speech so anyway we get hammered the
next day I'm by the way there's nothing
better than someone at a wedding that's
an unsolicited speech I mean they gave
it out but I was at a wedding with a kid
and he leans over because think about
giving a speech and he's like a little
tipsy I go are they taking speech to
just not what I'm doing
way and I go okay and he goes yeah
wife's telling me not to do it and I go
oh so you're not gonna like no I'm gonna
do it and I go all right and they they
just did this they did like the hey
welcome everybody and he gets he walked
all that was in a barn walked i was like
i like to say something she never runs
it is going on and gave the most awkward
speech you ever heard it's the best yeah
it really i mean like i would fan the
flames of an drunk person saying they're
going to get hurt I mean that to me is
like that I these things that's like
your whole bit about watching your
cousin's do PCP yeah well I was at a
wedding with when I sedate Dana back in
the day and her cousins wedding and this
guy came over to us and he knew we did
comedy and he was just starts he's
wasted already shown us how he did a set
one time and it was an hour and he
crushed the whole time his first time
ever and I'm just like oh here we go
yeah like same things I'm thinking about
giving a speech and we should definitely
do drum you should do the act do the
alcohol do you that our and he went up
unsolicited and did like a five-minute
awkward super awkward speed and then
after her cousin came over we're just
dying to say man what was that all about
were like oh like you didn't tell him to
do anything at all that's when we found
out was on Felicity like now he was but
he just got a engine went over there and
just started talking and she took
control you got rid of the move of
taking control I'm one away yeah but it
is for me let me hold on i know it is
love I want to have my moment inside
your a moment you guys it's great let's
make it more great come on me for five
minutes let me just riff I did an hour
one hour an hour there's a lot of
stories of people like you know I did it
once and it went really well you're like
that interesting number one if it's it
so so anyway so now the next day I'm
going to like a sports book to watch
football in the morning and I'm happy
and as I'm driving over time talking
with us and I'm happy I'm happy because
I was like supposed to be I should be on
a train right now hungover headed to
work but instead i'm going to the sports
book and as I'm driving over there you
know I asked a cabdriver about like
wheat I'm like where do you know is
there how hard is it to get weed here
nothing shady if it is we'd all right
nothing she driving man let's see che
dici mexican cab driver i don't know but
is there we'd hear
and he's like yeah for sure you know you
can just you can ask a cab drive you
could really ask anybody for weed
nothing okay good to know yoni cab
driver yes you got any cab drivers man
call some and so so buy some weed from a
crazy due to the bar like we you know we
go watch the sports book and I'm have a
great day no I'm with like basically two
to three buddies two of the guys who
gave the weirdest speeches ever I point
out that the first guy speech was insane
along and the second guy speech is
basically like I haven't talked to him
in 10 years but uh yeah so everyone was
like good exact day babble when I heard
Mexico's like I'm coming nobody yeah so
I'm with those two guys so it is so we
buy weed from this crazy due to the bar
and right away you know that it's bad
weed because it's like we're like thirty
dollars worth he just gives us like a
pound and I'm just like ugh Jesus Christ
what is this way we have to seem oh yeah
this is terrible so so we have that so
we go roll some joints whatever we're
hanging out I'm loving it going to pull
all that stuff having like a montage day
and roll some joints for just like
walking around and we're walking around
with being aware and then being aware
what are you talking like I'm watching
you know I'm like I is there anybody you
know nothing so we're having some drinks
and then and then I need to roll a joint
so then I'm going a joint like on this
little kind of darker area and then all
of a sudden there's cops sirens and my
one of my one of its me and the two
speech guys now at this point who I
don't I don't one of the guys I met like
literally the day before and so he's
like dude cops cops so I just throw the
weed down and we just start walking in
like these two cops come over and they
had the flashlights on us and I like
what do you guys doing man what do you
guys do and we're like oh not so we're
just walking around he's like walking
around smells like weed man smells like
weed over here we're like oh nothing we
got no idea what's going on are you on
the hotel property no we're just like
walking the street got it so we're being
really like I said really safe and I
know smart really smart and safe and I'm
a grown-up and so they put us up against
like they they're pissed and they like
throw us up against this [ __ ]
wall and I'm just like a [ __ ] this is
not this is my day this is my montage
day like I'm having my mom totally and
so we're up against the thing and
they're searching us and they don't find
anything and so I'm like okay and then
one of them's like there we go and I was
like oh [ __ ] because i thrown the weed
you know like in the bush or whatever
not the outback like on the ground and
so I through so I threw the weed and he
found it and it's you know it's a good
amount of it and he's like this is not
good guys it's not good and we're like
I'm ready just [ __ ] yourself away
Yeah right hitting how about you Gary
yeah it is Gary and this is it is going
it's actually Gary sir we could go to
that yeah yeah me as I'm burning myself
ready yeah yeah yes that's right exactly
Yeti thank you sir and yeah we're
[ __ ] I mean not only are we like is
on one shutting up or is it was a speech
givers now they try to give a [ __ ] we've
got our way i'll tell you what all that
so true because the speech giver the
main speech giver he's the one likes guy
like John and I'm just sitting there
frozen as is the other guy they cuff us
all together and they tell us to get in
the car and we're like guys guys guys we
don't have to do this we really where
this is okay like we can please please
get in the car get in the car we like
[ __ ] she gets us in the car as soon as
we get in the car the one dude who gave
the short speech he looks over to me and
he goes we shouldn't have gotten in the
car and I was like we just said just
wear 30 seconds ago these words we had
great value but I would have been like
what should we do let's talk more let's
not do this so in the back the car he's
driving us around one of them is just
laughing he doesn't speak a cop court
you're surely zarkoff this point cop car
sirens that's what alerted us initially
wear these every one of the radio yes
just the one goes on like that some
aspects of life is a deep ellum last
night wait a minute Judas told us we'd
so we're in the back of the cop car and
he's driving around and the one did is
just talking the other guy that would be
the hustle by the way if you had a cop
cousin you sell the weed you can tell
you
cousin you bought them you never lose
the weed that we ready put the [ __ ]
money yep god damn yeah that would be a
15 bucks i could go whatever you compile
them few pounds on here for that one
hour ya rabbana Mexico lot of wheel our
stressful our you just get them a block
away look away look here they come I
literally just bought this you're not
gonna believe this I went back I got a
risk damn it's my god hi man look I'm a
little hesitant about behind this third
bag the last things are weird beard now
I'm gonna do give me the bag and I'm
gonna put it up my ass and then nobody's
gonna know okay all right gotta be
kidding what you gonna be your hands man
[ __ ] wait hahaha damn right now good I
know this is my zoom level so he keeps
doing that he keeps not good right in a
cop car right now good that are your ya
back of a cop car handcuffed to two
batteries all three of the tank and one
got a related to comment true yeah I
don't knowi know either of them that
well you know I mean I like that long I
have known for a while and the other guy
is great like I've you know he's a good
dude like this bonds you to people and
so everything you know every two minutes
it's not good guys you [ __ ] up man if
you driving or just he there other guys
drive okay you are in and around your
mouth yeah we're moving no idea where
we're going freaking out like talking to
each other but we can do I mean how you
whispering like how they might we were
just like going like what the [ __ ] would
you would like I mean yeah this way
we're just we're gonna we're gonna
really like no I'm gonna do with it I'm
gonna EE ask man I hear that kind of
thing out there now boy yes yeah snap
their necks fan come up there right
there yeah you're not going to desert
expose their oh he can hear is there a
cage like in the cage just like a cab
well not even they don't even have he
was running the meter probably did yeah
good you bail 600 man that's what the
dreyfus 57
not rough so there's no barrier between
nothing here I don't but there it's not
like just two car seats like there's
there's definitely have some sort of
barrier but it's not like the glass or
age or anything kind of and you can't
get out did you try them did you try the
door you know no because when i got when
i was in high school once it's like my
first run in with the cops ever at boy
have there been a lot there's the murder
but i was in green lake wisconsin with
some of my buddies and we were drinking
underage i think we were probably like
probably 16 and we got into an argument
with some people nearby and they called
the cops the cops came they found beer
they breathalysed us put us you know put
us in the back of a cop car and as the
cop was driving i was like i wonder if
the doors locked and i literally opened
it and the door opened and she went
apeshit so I was like I'm not gonna I
was like I've tried opening doors before
and realized that it's not that fruit
especially if you're handcuffed 23 jun
yeah we're good point it's like let's go
guys run and we're not talking about
this part of the island over the door
coming over then we're going to snap
their necks you're not snapping our next
dude hey man we hear you I think the
year so so yeah so he just keeps saying
that we're look the one guys like sure
sure we will do anything sir we are so
sorry we were so sorry cuz I've seen a
lot of locked up abroad too mmhmm yeah
that show is like with more ever i
travel something right now yeah I have
anxiety right now so done and and there
are so many like and that's what that's
all I'm thinking about is like you know
when you see locked up abroad these you
walk into these jails it's like dude
it's not it makes you look at our jails
like penthouses like because it's just
like yeah you share a cell with 18 dudes
there's no law will give you rise
tomorrow you know and like so I'm I'm
worried so the guys gonna please please
sir please he's like men look at this
weed dude this is [ __ ] we'd you're going
to jail for like the dog [ __ ] we'd we're
like sir you don't need to disparage the
marijuana do you understand I mean I you
are like I'm a little high 630 joints
but he says just disparaging us tells
you do to pull over pulls over he gets
out and now I'm like hold on where are
you in the middle of nowhere well no
we're like you build oh no she
buildings but it's not we're not near
where we were we're like yeah it's not
know where you don't know where the [ __ ]
I am hey my phone said so Ne like you
know gpsing or anything Bob ladies
walking down from ah so I'm like okay oh
[ __ ] so and this is by the way the
sunday that you should have been bad for
a day that I should have been at work at
10am ideally but I was like I'm taking a
me day and it's now resulting in less so
he comes over he's like then I can't
believe you guys man he's like this weed
is still garbage we're like sir please
please anything and it goes it's not
just not good dude go to jail here man
they [ __ ] you up we're like sir we do
not because at this point we're like the
other hook line with exactly how you
want to go I will do anything I'll place
the shell game with this guy and lose
yeah I will pay so he's like it's going
to cost you guys we're like what what is
like man six hundred dollars and we were
like okay you have corporate media Lee
yeah I was not do a Jake I hear you but
that's his number of sorry but we don't
have that honor I gotta Jam a sock you
all right we'll get it why me to at
least be like now amazing thinking why
he wanted a portion 16 I was either not
in Mexico guy started saw before but
women we got a lock box out of Mexico
he's on the puddin suspending it to it
guys I would have saved us 250 I would
have saved it for the record I'm a
picker pants down what its name to get
him down a man yes but with the way you
just did it I'm okay with that you know
if he pulled over he's willing to good
now he's willing negotiate they said
yeah but like God there are these
episodes where like I mean in my head
right now I'm like I will do he could
have sent a million dollars i feel like
sir let me make some phone call I can
get I remember I was in Denver doing
comedy works and I got to stay in their
beautiful condo it's got this hot tub
that's overlooking they're not listen
wow it's great I'm just telling you
right I'm trying to getting it in yeah
I'm available too I'm sitting
in their condo watching locked up abroad
and if I got so much things like they
would just take the heroin and they and
then as they're going through security
haha I had to stop at something I went
out and sat like why am I in here
watching these people ruin their lives
that we looking at this I remember that
and I'm just carrying I like watching a
piccata it's just anxiety ridden all the
way to find out how you're gonna guess
now here comes this dude oh yeah they
want you to do this [ __ ] while you're in
there yes eight years later someone's
like the embassy called man you can go
here more like establish the latter
family I make wallet for a living out of
tape sir I don't know if I could go back
oh but I'm picturing like yeah the
freeze-frame like on me like that's when
I knew I was screwed right right then
600 bucks so he goes you go get six
hundred dollars to me and I was like
what it's like six hundred dollars when
I was like uh okay so he uncuffed me
from the two and I'm like big job yeah
good good I so I'm like work on your
speech is the president now I'll give a
great speech Friday all right dawg take
care I'll come back we'll break their
having a break the next way guys I might
know you can't so I'm like so I'm so
that is like the you know that is the
predicament where I'm like okay well I'm
uncuffed from these men now but I was
like no you gotta you know you gotta
kick could just get [ __ ] for eight
years in jail by strangers so so I was
like okay I'm gonna go do this so I'm
like I'm running around I go to and this
is what's crazy to when I asked someone
for an ATM when i was there like the day
before they were like boy ATM that's not
a good answer I've done I went and there
was like a line like there was like an
autograph line where there was like 18
people deep like waiting for one ATM so
I was like I this is not going to be
that easy so I find some places I'm just
trying to get as much as I can I get a
hundred bucks out of one and then I'm
running around and I was the max on that
it was the max and I'm like I could i
don't think i could get that one to
english so i was like freaking out time
running
I sell them like where the [ __ ] were we
paying six hundred dollars of
international bank charges well I've
done it before I guarantee you at chase
like someone's alarm on their computers
is job we go come on everyone Gary yeah
we gotta help Gary s so so I'm able to
get out like with debit cash back and
with ATM usage get like 175 hours that's
it that's it that's all I can get and
I'm like and I have a little bit on my
phone so I like how long is it taking
you while they're waiting I mean
probably like a half hour but it felt so
like yeah it felt like two and a half
hours so I was trying I remember about
two times and lack of a rut yeah and why
and lack of a broad time it felt like
two and a half hours in reality it was
probably 20 minutes and your phone says
you can't call it a little bit it boosts
so I like shut it off when it won the
[ __ ] was hitting the fan so I turn it on
its got like two percent on it so I call
chase immediately and then it died
doesn't like a kick [ __ ] so then I go
back to the car and I'm like sweaty and
I'm freaking out and I'm like sure all I
can get is 175 all I can get is 175 he's
175 he's like what did you know expected
mocking me more and I'm like I get it
i'm a dirtbag whatever i'll do anything
so he lets that he cuffs me back into
the team now so now I'm cuffed to the
initial long speech guy as short weird
speech goes running off fine he's
running off and then I'm sitting in the
back and you don't know if he's ever
coming back my mouth yeah that was your
demand that I think I came back
[ __ ] Sam stop in the neck to the
left or you could have just got some
money but you were you weren't allowed
no no it did ah so that's sitting there
I'm talking about anxiety none stop
talking [ __ ] he still is going like only
one on the vine okie dokie it's not good
if you don't come back with a good
amount of money dude that's not good for
you guys and I was like dude please just
stop I mean is you at hey what has my
life gone did you tell others the other
do that your handcuffs ooh I'm gonna be
honest I really someone had it I gosh so
he you're probably next we're going to
be a treat know it
honestly like I don't know what but
that's what I'm thinking I'm like okay
well I'm able to get a 175 who knows
about this time like this guy's not
going to get out anything and did you
give them the 175 no they even just let
you hold on to it for now yeah they're
right know yet i wait to get it like
other night he goes while you were gone
I play poker good guy we're down another
teacher so now he's gone into the night
he's gone he's probably about a half
hour uh he comes back he was able to get
out like something so meager like made
ma it was almost like you know what
trains planes and automobiles were Steve
Martin negotiates for his hotel yeah but
it's like you're like yeah I'd buy that
and then then John Candy like gives them
a burnt credit card and a watch in like
eight dollars my guys like man I'm think
so he comes back like the burnt credit
card in the watch like he's got nothing
he's got like 70 bucks 50 bucks ersan
are you're getting killed for ya like
let it go man try debit I almost got
killed again so so we put that together
the other dude has I don't even know
what his reason was he just couldn't he
didn't he had like fifty pesos on him
and he's like that's all I have so then
the cop was sitting there and then he
was like this is not good guys and he's
like but I you know what I'm going to
take it easy on you guys I'll take this
and you guys can get out of here and we
were like I couldn't believe it he he
took the cuffs off you think we get it
weeping we took the cuffs off we're
running we're running [ __ ] yeah you're
running and then one of them's like I
felt the weight on me we saw the way he
still had the we have you did that so
then we went back we were like still
smoking the weed hidden at the hotel at
the hotel yeah I was like sales robbery
yeah point I was like I've learned a
valuable lesson today about Mexican law
enforcement first of all you are
definitely I mean at that point getting
back to the hotel smoking a joint then
gonna you must have been [ __ ] I got
it yeah it reminds okay so tell your
[ __ ] show or another no I don't know
my god no no I it was there was a ten
high school in Milwaukee we would have
like we could get we couldn't get beer
like we could you know was impossible
when you were like 16 or 17 there it was
just there was no way they knew fake IDs
for the most part we weren't getting
them good
and and we had this guy who wasn't all
there who used to go buy us beer and he
would always mess it up because he was
you know he was missing you know he was
not all there and so he would come out
and he would like give us like some what
of what we'd ordered we'd pay and water
right ordered yeah we would be like if
we get a cardinal Winston we could go
crazy with him look like they got porn
sex and porn get two cases of beer two
bottles cap morgan so one time that my
friend's dad caught him unloading beer
for us and went crazy on him he's like
you're 23 what are you doing hanging out
with high schoolers and the guy started
crying and then when he when we found
out that our buddy's dad was going to be
cool to him we found him at a Denny's
and we told him that he wasn't going to
get in trouble and he started crying
again he's like I'm so happy this is the
best day of all that's what I felt like
at the end of this year I can't believe
my lucky stars I was because I was like
resigned to the next chapter being a
prison well we all know what happened to
that guy outside the other daddies you
went to we all remember that story from
the way it's crappy which was not your
story no I'm saying Kirk's wasn't it I
don't know I was like that was your LJ
doesn't even have any idea here to tonys
somebody fun event where I know you from
yeah so that was God so I had I work we
used to work this hotel when I first
moved here and there were a lot of
bellman that were Mexican dudes and we
were all tight we hung out all the time
and they would roll they all drove
lincoln town cars older ones but nice
one right and they had the California
tags obviously and it will all go to
Rosarito and they would tell me all the
time as soon as they see that tag they
pull you over and they give you some
[ __ ] and this is what I was waiting
yet me to say was when the guy said 600
because the one dude said to him 200 so
they went through all that [ __ ]
where he went and got the 200 brought it
back and then they go for each other I'm
he had to go leave again get 200 more
for his partner and I thought you were
going to say the same [ __ ] I if you did
all that they're like for both of no no
well I mean yes maybe would have evaded
money so you realize if I was there with
you when we finally got like oh shoot
for me oh we're gonna go out for 81st
yeah Jake so looking to fight I've got
off for third of the price fence he saw
well and then like goddammit scary ma'am
I would've gone make my stomach hurt
well i'll look for the shilla you know
like when i go to like like if i go to
like Australia or something for the
dollop or like I just so aware that what
I'm so aware of like not messing up the
DLA you know what I mean like I no
trouble never want any trouble this was
for whatever reason my mind was just
clicked on to like hey is fun you get
fun here at it just the second it
happened Julia it's like anything else
the second that you know right after a
car accident of the second you see a cop
pulling everything I am such an idiot
and I was just sitting there like man
I'm gonna like be gone for like three
days in jail that means done if I was
that cop I wish I would have been like
you know what leave you shirts hahaha
leave your shirt Ashley after 20 years
let's when your partner's start to get a
little weird Getty that they meant back
there why did you keep asking for their
shirts and shoes man to [ __ ] with the
best 35 years on board okay okay if
you're gonna lick the inside of each
other's hands alright what do you got
what are you literally build and the
other one you to skip around in for 20
minutes and weasel shoes and let's see
no shoelaces and then you eat your
shoelaces like spaghetti I'd say I love
a spaghetti I'm gonna tell you him
because I really should get out of here
we got some money dude nah he's gonna
eat his legs it's like I mean is late
yeah yeah that would be nice [ __ ] you do
while you're waiting for them to get
back with ya definitely when you get
back you [ __ ] out the lace sing total
eclipse about try to harmonize and we're
going to do it five times till we get it
right the whole dog krebbs Marie
occupants imma get the bears Papa you
can subvert over there and you
masturbate okay haha and it's just a fun
huh all right leave your shoes and your
laces hey welcome to Mexico have you
have you ever been arrested here yeah
what would you get arrested for are you
comfortable clogging away yeah I got a I
got a DUI like nine years ago mmm where
well
uh right in front of my house oh you had
a parking yeah oh I'm gonna hit you
gardless yeah well I was in the hell I
was in a highway or pulling up and I was
Travis part i was literally I was
putting it in reverse when I saw and I
wasn't like I wasn't like like blackout
drunk and was like oh no like I didn't
see him the whole time I've been running
away I was like literally put in Reverse
saw the tire and I was like god it's
very long life I let's see a lot of
lines through the love like sorry it was
another DJ ha but he was like yeah so
and it's very much like the those
commercials were like the second you
know you see and you like change your
mirror you change the rearview and
you're like no this wasn't good and then
your car fills up with vodka and martini
olives you're like oh god I was like a
dead man walking like this to me
everything is I gave him around here
he's like put your hands on the cars
like all right what he do for fun my man
you know he's like how many of you had I
was like all right just the business
will get to the facts but yeah so he
what gave him the alarm to pull you over
uh well what what had happened was I was
doing a show and I was I am I work a lot
consistently and and I and like as i was
leaving go with you in Long Beach not
terribly long ago and not terribly long
beach ego photo log so yeah yeah I
discrimination um but so on the way like
basically I got onto my drive home I was
like I'm gonna get some Doritos and
normally I would have just taken the 101
always that fun and so yeah so I like
one bought a bag of Doritos and I was
just like eating Doritos driving again
over the limit for sure but not like
[ __ ] canned and then yeah and then I I
guess I was speeding I don't know what
the actual I don't even think I asked I
was just like he caught me yeah whatever
it is it's over take my Doritos yeah and
then and then he I got booked downtown
and then I was in the drunk tank for p2p
downtown LA County yeah that's supposed
to be a frightening terrifying the drunk
tank the drunk tank is such an
interesting joining the good time drunk
because it isn't it so be ready to fight
if I was you
go in there and it's like you're all
drunk with terrible new news so it's
like dive in there like it's just
everywhere like people are going to want
to fight they're drunk they're angry I
looked into some eye contact there would
like there was this dude who was just
nuts and I was just like you know kind
of my eyes are just scanning the room
and I looked into and he's like that
[ __ ] cop with those cuffs on too hard
man and I was like alright so not not
gonna get anybody know I honestly what
happened was there was a my cop let me
go in and get my night pan sure now he's
making a dream making a vision board
I've been here for weeks I love the drug
pan I they let me go and get my own
toothbrush I was right in front of my
house when they got me good night the
grad night man nice is my pets bro you
know exactly little song about man
they're turning to de-pants for me
things are not good but so I had to piss
real bad and it was like 30 dudes and
there's just like a toilet right in the
middle and I was like trying to just
couldn't piss I was like my dick head my
penis was overwhelmed with the world
that I was in I was standing there and
you know when you can't pee from then
you are like no I'm not peeing right now
and everyone said everyone done and then
you go I'll do a fake Sheikh like I peed
you know you kind of play it off so I
play off my pee like I paid and you
heard nothing nothing came out of me by
peed and then i SAT back down how big
did you check out that shake no big wow
it was people jinkies yeah feat on the
back of the toilet in here just I'm just
jerking off at some point sir I just
shaking her out um so I so then
basically like the whole time I was like
dying of piss poison I was like sitting
there like oh my god and this guy tells
me he's like who's been arrested before
for drunk driving he's like they'll let
us out at like 5am when I was like okay
so I was just sitting there watching the
clock like a finally I want to take the
world's biggest piss at 5am they call
seven names and they give us a pillow
and a sheet and I was like I don't think
this is what they give people who are
leaving this place and then they walk
are you one of the seven oh yeah yeah
and I'm with the dude who is I was the I
contacted I get cuffed the eye contact
oh my god they caught me to him and he
hope they weren't too too tight for him
on that Ricky he would have been he
wouldn't shut up and I was just like man
I really hate my buddy and uh and then
yeah then they took us to the regular
jail and then I was about to explode
from urine so that I finally was like I
gotta just I pissed the biggest piss of
all time in yourself well it was like a
shared cell there was probably like 25
dude oh geez but it's big bunk beds and
stuff and I nice he was actually pretty
fun are you acting all those bungalows
or anything I dude I was like I mean
yeah you have no shoes on our way you're
walking from drunk tank yeah into the
system yeah is it big and open and sells
everywhere like you see on some of these
yeah I was a lawyer now I was no I
wasn't like I went walking through like
the thing where they're just like your
minds because no no no are you hold your
little clothes yeah why not they say
when you go to jail first thing you did
find the scariest baddest to do suck his
dick oh my god there's a leader like hey
you know you can go right oh I brought
my night pants yeah and then and then I
was just in there that my book how long
for like 13 hours it was it in the total
process and was the rest of those people
in that cell also for their for drunk no
they were like now there were definitely
like some criminals in yeah yeah but I
just like sat on the bunk bed and just
shut up but I didn't take a sip of water
the whole time I was there maybe because
I was dying oh yeah / hydration that was
about to explode and then my buddy
picked me up because I like sent the
best text message out you know 82 in the
morning like hey I don't freak out i'm
just in jail you know and I was like
there's my phone for the next 13 hours
and I came out I called my buddy to pick
me up and he was like i'll tell you i've
picked up a few people from dui's before
you're handling it the best okay yeah
pretty good and then I had to go to a
commercial audition right after wall
swear to God I got like one of the
messages from my commercial agent yeah I
was like I'll go and I didn't change or
anything and I just went to the
commercial audition of this girls like
have you been I was like I'm pretty good
mad
I'm depressed that was in jail right
before this oh my god did you book it I
didn't that have been great I did then
he likes it no book tonight a sonic
campaign I booked it I'm in a million
dollars then I bought a boat I should
tell you guys about that about a boat
for a million dollars i'm in on the
sonic campaign you did no tell smoke I
can't it's the end of it want to talk
about this uh show in Vancouver so well
this huh I was doing a show I do a lot
of shows and I'm mr. soon the uh I don't
know how epic of a story this is but
basically there was I love Vancouver by
the way all right so well this is a
crate this whole weekend was insane so
basically i'll just i'll try to clifton
at the beginning a little bit but
basically we have time I don't show
someone show no so I get there and I'm
like I meet up with a buddy of mine and
he's like you know let's go to a strip
club and I was like okay and we went
there and that that's kind of how i am
at strip clubs now where I'm sorta like
I don't think I want to be here at all
you know so we were flying there for
like 10 minutes and then we were like
this is a terrible decision then we
talked to this we talked to this girl
and she's she seems cool and she's like
all my friends a dancer here and so
we're just kind of hanging out for a
little while and you know that makes it
more fun because then we're just hanging
out we're not being the strip club was
crazy by the way and then so act or just
know they had a shower on stage and like
there was just a lot of water on the
stage so I was like that rain I hope so
all the girls around slowly just fills
up a dress yes he did free all right
it's pretty wrong not really hot when
there's yet at the end they really work
at the end so she so she's like she's
like showing us pictures on her phone
and she's like she's like into like you
know bondage stuff and she loves to get
spanked and she's showing us these crazy
pictures on her phone of her ass words
like you know just welted what beyond
what you know you to the point where
you're like well I just don't understand
you're like a grandpa you're like what
is just seems unfair to you and uh and
then so we go we go
cool she's like you guys want to go to
this this party my friends having I like
sure we'll go to that so we go to this
party and it's a really crazy crew of
like pierced people & and then they she
introduces us to the guy whose house it
is she lives there yes yes I am life oh
yeah Sam yeah I mean victor is and we're
go to that part i know this is shady
year and i was gonna be yelling oh yeah
for sure uber what do you want to do so
then we get there and yeah the dude
whose house it is is just pierced to
[ __ ] and he has a split tongue old he is
a bifurcating yeah I forget it I
fricative that called that's just yeah
I'm and I work a lot of snakes surface
serpent some serpent tongue he's got the
split tongue and eases how do I know
that did he tell you how you do that you
got to go to someone cuts it someone
like cuts your tongue and a half and I
mean obviously but how does it how does
that he'll I didn't think a tongue every
[ __ ] healed well his isn't healed
this is flip I thought solving like I
mean it's a bloody oh no yes i said is
on permanently char you know is worth it
get the call two years about worth it I
thought I've got a gun it's never gonna
wow thats ever no no I you would hope it
would go back together but I can never
seen that oh it's not as you have a
crazy lisp does that give you a list
yeah you know these couple years ago on
the outside I really regret yeah I
reckon why would you voiceover I make my
money doing voiceover and I'm stimulus
but you know that career is over I'm a
gardener oh it's been a tough run I'm a
landscaper yeah yeah I'm a landscaper in
you know whatever it's fine I did pick a
card stuff for a long time so it's nuts
right so my buddy's like I'm out of here
but I'm like at this point like you know
talk to the girl and this seems we going
alright so my god okay we'll hang in
there and then so then her friend is the
strippers there too and you know she's
like this season I like my best friend
also my god Alan off she's like my best
friends died on the stage tonight
cinnamon dance she's dead and so so it's
all very insane he's putting like a cool
work screw through his nose dude he's
got tons of holes you're the cop you
know like [ __ ] Lollapalooza sure well
with people there so it's not like a
raging thing and it's definitely you
know that you know how it is ones like
if you're like if you're there if you're
in town for stand up and you go
somewhere there's a lot of people how is
it you know and you're like doing a lot
of that so we're like shooting that [ __ ]
well anyway so i hook up with the girl
we go to the bathroom and we we hook up
the bond the bot the girl who we met at
the strip club initially and and we hook
up a little bit but then you know it's
like 4am or something so eventually i'm
like 'look come to the show tomorrow
night you know hang out after whatever
she's like okay cool and so then the
next the next day I'm like texting
weather and she's like hey can I bring
the guy from last night and my friend
who's the stripper girl you know my best
friend I'm like oh yeah for sure you
know I was kind of thinking like a two
person saying you know cuz I was even
saying let's meet for a drink before
whatever but she's like I wants to bring
up to my client so then I go to do the
show they're there and I'm like probably
ten minutes into my set when there's
just like a chatty corner and not under
a lot of it yeah the guy's like this
guy's [ __ ] I've got leaves all over
me I probably could work I usually do
voiceover any of coors light so but you
know like when you hear chatty and
you're like it's not enough to engage it
because maybe other people don't hear it
but it bothers you but you're like I'll
plow through so I'm plowing through but
then it's starting to get real lippy and
I look over and I'm just like what do
they do I just see like this whole table
and kind of chaos and I'm like what are
you I'm like that i think they're trying
to help someone to the bathroom so i'm
going to the bathrooms there that you
you guys should be able to figure it out
it's right there you know something and
then someone goes call 911 he's having a
heart attack and I was like oh [ __ ] and
I was like uh so I don't know what to
say so then the lights kind of come up
and then they start moving stuff around
and they're laying a guy down and then
so I'm like all right everybody become
you know like I still doing your boots
value same I would prob you what you see
you know I was like lat
I was right in the setup of it was just
about to get good the bit you know about
my people with their kids on facebook in
the pictures and so I'm like right there
you're like 40 minutes in it I was like
45 minutes into the one bit that I have
you know when I really milk it well the
only set I've done was an hour and I
improvised it but it went pretty good
yeah so I'm so I'm just up there like
okay and then I have it recorded and at
one point you know they're laying them
down this dude is having a heart attack
you know the bifurcated tongue guys like
you need any you need a rake I have a
race Anna and so at one point I'm up
there and at one point I just go I I
still holding the mic and I'm still just
standing on stage and I'm just like I
don't know what my role is here like and
I just kind of say that to myself and
then or you tip that wasted all right
guys but it paid in the bit because that
is what happen and and then the pyramid
cuz it's Canada the paramedics come
super fast they get him out they put him
on a stretcher he leaves the table
leaves people are chattering the lights
go down I've had no contact with anyone
who works at the club how long we
talking about hi about 15 to 20 minutes
well that's impressive for them to get
their say brewed have a heart attack out
and bounced yeah yeah it really one they
probably were looking out for you too
well I've guys I'm not have a good bit
household out of it come on keep going
man will be fine clear so yeah it was
pretty clear we lost it but we should
have taken to the hospital this guy is
only a boy a minute I'd say I really
took my cute only magic I am this person
who's talking oh ma'am your husband's
dead if you're gonna cry get out front
this guy's good this guy is good does a
lot of shows over I bet it does
as we can often and talks about us up so
he rolls or leaves you know and he's ok
I find out in the long run he's okay and
then I literally do jump right back in
with the joke and then you know and then
just talked about the fact that I never
you've never you never prepare yourself
for a man having a heart attack during
your show like you picture someone could
you know get angry at you or someone
will talk to you but you never picture a
man almost dying so they're there for
this the you know the the three people
the one girl from the night before the
man with the tongue I forgot about them
yeah they're still here they're still in
existence I take so many show the
baseball uh-huh yeah this is the show
they saw so after you know they're like
was that plan don't look now and I know
my gosh this is not what plan yeah I
mean I planted and then i won't vamp
well for 20 minutes then you'll leave
and i'll jump in awkwardly so that'll be
i'll pay for this experience so they
after we're going out and i'm like it's
a me and my buddy these people a couple
of other people and I'm you know like
I'm like with her I'm trying to figure
out like what you know it's just kind of
weird so I one point we're sitting at
the table all of us and someone says to
the guy about the girl that I was was
meeting up with he goes how long have
you two been together and the guy was
like two years and I was like oh that's
the wrestler if I'm sorry I questioned
from the back it's just doing some ass
over here and I'm like okay so I just
quietly process that I don't say
anything I'm like okay it's just
interesting to know well who do you
think's video on your normal time I need
someone with flair a man with the tongue
of two so so I like sitting nice never
moving to another bar and it's a three
of you know it's like eight or eight of
us at this point but my buddy these
three people and the girl and then so as
we're walking over the place they called
my buddy I'm like hey
that girl just at the table just the bad
to his better boyfriend for two years he
was like what he's like you he hooked up
with her and i was like i did last night
in his house sounds like okay so he had
corpses over haha he had two lollipops
at the same time this guy's amazing so
so we go to the next place when I talked
to her and I'm like I'm like hey why did
he say that you guys have been together
for two years she's like oh well he's my
boyfriend and she's my girlfriend we're
polyamorous and I was like oh and she's
like yeah we just live in that house and
we can kind of do whatever like share
whatever and I was like oh great i'll be
back tonight do you think she's cool no
but then i was like awesome it has been
great to spend eight hours figuring this
out tonight with you guys and it was
like four in the morning and when I went
home and that but I didn't even I wasn't
even aware that those that that was a
such an open thing the whole time I but
if the whole time I was like what is
going on like she's being weird he said
they're together hey Kour all these time
here more and more we said uh Liza
treyger come on and tell that sex story
about she had a foursome with a
threesome in the crowd like they
basically they went out with her after
they were like listen here's the deal
we're here all we're all gonna [ __ ] each
other would you like to join us and she
said more and more women she knows are
going to these types of sex parties and
stuff well I mean I'm would have been
the lizards guy like you know these guys
are probably into some I should also
point out she had a sugar glider so
there's another bit like Sugar Claire
yeah dude they're like these little like
of these little almost gerbils that fly
what yeah you never seen a sugar other
amazing it's like a little gerbil that's
why I think I think science might not
like me i 100% on what I said here look
at and what the dish are you saying they
like shoot up there asking something
nope that was not what I was insinuating
no no saying a lot like that did it
really here's what it is but they can
fly Oh a real animal it's not a muskrat
yes an animal I think flies around the
way I must have described it horribly
then call sugar glider like how far can
it fly sounds like it's a lady lives it
can't it can't fly but it
glide like it like drop from the ceiling
or something ya know you just take it to
a building and drop it funlife the sugar
glider has here it is I don't like all
that [ __ ] they had one yeah what are you
talking about it's like a wombat how big
is this tiny like this big and you're in
there the fourth um dude anything I'm
lying around the house it wasn't lying
hahaha tri glide they glide it wasn't
gliding off like the chandeliers Rome
with a guy I older and go hey Frank save
Isis claims on his tongue you gotta get
that guy going fam how what him in
between my thumb they don't fly given
the old tug come here baby Eddie just
stores him in about living here roll
along yeah I roll my me living room also
he can kiss both of those girls at once
yeah and probably was and I the whole
time I was like I met a girl that I
think is pretty cool you have till the
end I was like are you [ __ ] everyone
okay well I'm gonna head back to the
Hilton or a shittier how the sheraton
Sheridan I mean it the first time eating
f of the same I still don't just go on
record said those things don't fly your
any light they glide I get it but you
didn't see it glide did you know when
you're sorry I'm sorry it's alright i
didn't see NZ glad I'm sorry man I was
just grabbing a watch this and chucked
it he's like that was a cat oh [ __ ] Rio
tiny kitchen you want you didn't happen
to be present when it might have been up
in the chandelier and just took a lumber
fry encounter you invented the
chandelier you've been played on the
stand I will not you know they're there
might have been one of the South it walk
it was hanging from a beer yeah fine is
the glide over to the back of the couch
to the left oh no that would never leave
it was good you could get you have
access to them I can get your sugar
glider by to any time is it it makes
angry alone what is it technically I
don't even know it's a muskrat it's not
a month it is a muskrat family I looking
at
out what it was our four minutes and i
know i think it's closer to a while I
had family that animal Tyrians excuse me
mm-hmm that is not here let's find out
what is a sugar glider not the first
time i've googled this who [ __ ] name
to the sugar lines like it takes that
every letter is a small omnivorous a
boreal and nocturnal gliding possum
belongings I marsupial in for class how
far do you love me or not uses that guy
have a pocket that's what I'm are that
you will I know what I guarantee doesn't
so you got a pocket little chest pot
picture looks like a dog Fred why does
your sugar glider have a pocket yeah I
know my phone just said you're a doctor
right I'm saying the home does this
sugar caca sighs pets they fit in your
pocket yeah no I don't think I don't
know if they have a pocket they prefer
chandeliers too proud chandeliers and
polyamorous relationships that's a weird
I mean it's pretty cool thing that he
does it's like those squirrel suits
those guys jump down the mountain yeah
from the chandelier from the sconce they
glide yeah they glide a glide um you
said you just met what is it in
Australia another marsupial pakka akka
wakka wakka what is a kwaka oquawka is a
marsupial so it's a lot like a muskrat I
just okay I had nothing to do i I'm just
as far as the Kwok ago I just want to
say I'm on there you know I mean I just
don't want take a stance against them
what do you eat your your I'm just I
don't wanna I'm just going on record
here with a story that I'm pro quokka
your pro clock and whatever comes from
this I just don't want to be looped into
an antiquark no I'm very Pro quokka I
love you are I mean they're delicious no
I I really do like I love like when
whatever I go to Australia boy like he
goes what are you doing shows I do show
new in Australia give a TV shoulder I
gotta go I can't I don't have a TV show
oh but um but you're big enough alien
huge but I don't talk about it um but so
you see me there March a their march
eight i'll be at the comedy store Sydney
but so Dave knows that I like
you know I watch a lot of like the new
planet Earth just came out and I like
can't get over how I mean like those are
my favorite things like watching like
nature documentaries and stuff so dave
was like telling me about these qua cos
and I was like what the hell are these
and he's like others you know they look
like Chipmunks is essentially what they
look like like they look like they look
like the alvin and the chipmunks
characters if you were to make them
actual here I'll show you how big are
they they're not that big they're like
I'm showing Sonali oh boy they're like
yeah they're like the size of like a
nerf football but they're there they're
adorable okay because people who are
listening so how big we talking up to
your mid shin now they're not even not
even at very low I mean they vary in
size try to get a hug here on no I don't
I don't hate it oh I don't know face
yeah eight inches not quite a foot not
quite a foot right up to like a third
Eagle animation quality I gotta go but
uh so he take Dave takes place called
rottenness island and yeah people are
like abuse of the Kwok is like that is a
whole thing really oh really yeah people
they're like yeah they think it's funny
they would light or some people do but
they would be like people are lighting
them on fire just why taking them yeah
could but you go to this island and
they're they're everywhere and that's
what people do there as they beat up on
Kwok is well people go there to see them
but there was a time when people yet
we're being like [ __ ] the caucus huh
yeah and so they're marsupials so they
have these big pouches to like the
mothers will put the pretty it's pretty
crazy looking but they're adorable but
everybody just tries to like take a
picture with me just like that's
basically it's a point why you go there
you go there to take a selfie real quick
but I wanted to like hang out you know
so so we kind of splinter off eventually
because they're just all over and we're
finding our own quad cos and we're both
trying to get picked why do you go in a
group look at the group no no just me
and Dave we don't like split off from
each other at it and as we're like you
know we're finding them and petting some
but they really they're really skittish
so they run off right away so basically
as our days ending we're like okay well
let's walk you know we'll walk back and
we're going to take a ferry back we're
gonna get a bite to you real quick and
as we're walking back there's like one
more little pack of the qua cos and I'm
like okay and I just go up to this one
and and I just start like giving a
little head rub you know like right the
top of his head and he right away like
his body play which is just like you
know when someone gives you a massage
like
like he's just like uh yeah so he's just
like into something I'll have rahama
really yeah you dared at all no no his
buddies are like Carl what the hell you
doing man he's like let me up a guy sick
last move it so I'm just like robbing
his head his eyes and uh and then I put
my other hand out and he he as I'm
giving his little head rub you he puts
his chin on on my hand like on my index
finger so he's now like kind of sleepy
yes I a cool so I'm doing that and daves
Davis taking some pictures and he's like
I want to get in and get a couple
pictures of you think i can swap it oh
my god I'll give the world now give the
world so we kind of so we kind of you
know do this thing where like he puts
his finger in and then we may quickly
make the shift and then Dave got him
under his finger and he's still cool
because they've given ahead robucket
pictures and I'm like dude I'm gonna
pick him up and he's like I'll he goes a
cuz I don't know you know I'm like no
I'm gonna wipe my eyes an animal yeah so
yeah for sure out of it I know ours is
going really good hey why don't ya go
wrong let's make it one with my rooms on
the snake's tongue oh here my back so
sounds like song from that fort guy
better that snake snake is just like a
good snake it isn't a good good it's
your tongue is slit this is not good man
so two humans get away with petting and
massaging this quokka now you're about
to pick this thing and now I'm like
let's roll the dice so and all the other
ones still right there too they haven't
run out there and people are walking by
like staring at us so then I gotta go
blowing gently haha gonna light him on
fire in it I think he came envelope y
con him into it so so then day you know
so that Dave's done so then I just go
over there I just grabbed a little thing
and I just pick him up put him in my
arms and he's into it and he just starts
like nuzzling and like he's like not
going in my armpit and he's like in you
know what I'm up real quick do you have
a way with I you an animal I mean you
love planet Earth but like our animals
like oh yeah okay the most part well
okay real quick side story I one time
went to quit smoking cigarettes to this
guy called the mad Russian in Boston his
name was you finish events off and he
basically would hypnotize you
to try had a lot of your family bring a
card how's mrs. shibin and then so he
hypnotizes me you do one-on-one he does
is crazy like hypnotist thing and then
you close your eyes at one point and he
makes a noise he's like picture yourself
smoking he's rushing the picture
yourself smoking and you see like a room
it's a very accurate impression I work a
lot how would I got that if you had not
said he's rushing i would have been
likes guys definitely rushed me thank
you i must do a lot of shows yeah it
looked lots too many yeah yeah what's
probably even counted exactly so so he
goes he said he does you pick that he's
sitting next to me after it I opened my
eyes you sitting next to me that's where
it goes you have an incredible ability
to heal animals he said that yeah and
then I got it I can look at my dog he's
dying I can't cook baked salmon you
don't leave so you think you work here
for your film so that I walked out I was
like what the hell just happened and I
never have thought and I've never liked
found like a you know like a sick deer
and been like we need to get a scalpel
you know like there's no actual healing
but I do love animals I've always liked
you know gravitated towards them because
humans don't get me mostly shows I talk
about in front of animals just so you
guys know their mittens and dogs yeah
and so the clock is nuzzled in and
people is it like someone's just like
never seen anything new I'll get a lot
of fluid on it will go up more than July
so so then I have like 10 minutes where
I'm just like petting us dude you know
it's tough send down on the ground you
know have a teary goodbye then we go to
get a bite to eat and he show up at the
window yeah it's little baseball hat on
out of that one and my brother Simon
wear a sweater but Dave Anthony day
totally this day would be the perfect
name for the clock in chipmunk movie so
we got this little cafeteria that's
there and uh and I really am like I
can't get over what just happened so
we're ordering food and I just say to
the woman is like ordering the food for
us I'm just like I just held the clock
in my arms for 20 minutes she goes Waka
they riddled with disease what haha
clears get it riddled she said if I we
light them on fire Kickham then I got
salmonella chlamydia and I'm sorry yeah
and she was like a shouldn't take a map
and I was like oh sweet mother of god so
then I took what like my shirt off and I
went to the bathroom that's almost be
like I never seen this before like this
mother [ __ ] idiots everything I guess
maybe it's a price I'm right Rach I mean
I've a 20 I paid for or neg don't tell
him don't tell him not to pick him up
man don't see how far does my god so
then like wash my is urgent and then the
rest of the day I was like every time I
took a pencil just waiting for seven
hour to burn my clothes Oh walk dude it
was it was quite a capper to that I've
heard that about koala bears before like
they have yeah STDs or so I mean yeah
what's up well I hope that she just
walked back to I just know that American
many look at this fool now I pick up
anymore cause I told them you got a
kwaka you go right now right now you
have your gonna hang on a chip yeah well
I've got a different state getting put
its knives in your arms I you've got ice
yeah whatever here to go anyway french
fries for you guys oh my god oh this has
been a lot of fun hold on is that
rushing all you hear you well sort of
because I quit for like a year but I
really think I wanted to quit and then I
started again and do you smoke now no
not cigarettes now we get it Matt no no
I want equipment what do you mean we get
it ah well it's why it's been great to
have you back long time to one that'll
definitely are not sure about this we'll
see we'll put it down in line yeah let
me load it up load it up to the
producers and I'd love to I think this
podcast could be a movie so this one
specific episode this episode
yeah I mean maybe made for TV but we'll
figure it out you know there's a lot of
angles while they saw me because I just
doing a lot of shows yeah and I didn't
know you'd have time or we would called
you before he should have yeah yes so
they should have done you guys you'll
figure it up well in all some serious
serious in all fairness in all well I
know you know it's serious when you get
into serious I know real I want to say
thank you for being here thank you yes
Ben you're a lot of fun always one at
one more time plug and promote whatever
you'd like well the dollop is going on
tour shows coming up or so more so many
one by yourself and with people oh [ __ ]
on my show and I have chlamydia you can
find all about it at dollar podcast com
where did you go get tested when you got
back just to see no I just waited well I
nobody to the [ __ ] checkup and thank
you so the sugar glider can hold
foursome now has chlamydia now [ __ ] we
get it I think we look no further than
the bifurcated Doug when the clap gets
in the picture doll podcast calm and
then list of the dollop and listen to
point versus point at Reynolds Gareth on
social media I love you too very much
like no I love you you know that rate
should have got that right I know it all
right love you guys awesome and I was a
lot of fun at Jay Larson calm be calm
Jay Larson comedy on all social media
Ryan Sickler com Ryan ticklin all social
media will talk to you all next Tuesday